>>> NEARLY 200 NATIONS HAVE
FINALLY REACHED A COP26 CLIMATE
AGREEMENT IN GLASGOW, SCOTLAND.
IT COMES AFTER MARATHON TALKS
AMID TENSION NEGOTIATIONS AFTER
THE SUMMIT ENDED.
>> SO INTENSE THAT TALKS WENT
INTO OVERTIME AS DEEP DIVISIONS
REMAINED ON KEY ISSUES LIKE
UNPRECEDENTED LANGUAGE ON FOSSIL
FUELS AND HOW MUCH MONEY
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES SHOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO ADAPT TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS.
CNN'S PHIL BLACK WITH MORE.
>> Reporter: ADOPT THE DECISION
ENTITLED CLIMATE GLASGOW PACT,
IT IS SO DECIDED.
>> Reporter: THEY GOT THERE IN
THE END.
APPLAUSE, BUT NO REAL JOY.
THE END RESULT, AN INTENSELY
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT THAT, AT
BEST, ACHIEVES INCREMENTAL
PROGRESS, AND ULTIMATELY FALLS
SHORT FOR EVERYONE.
AT A CLIMATE CONFERENCE, THAT
COUNTS AS A WIN.
THE FINAL DRAFT INSPIRED
PASSIONATE SUPPORT FROM SOME
WORLD COUNTRIES.
>> THIS IS GOOD.
THIS IS A POWERFUL STATEMENT.
>> I PLEASE IMPLORE YOU, PLEASE,
EMBRACE THIS TEXT SO THAT WE CAN
BRING HOPE TO THE HEARTS OF OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
>> Reporter: VULNERABLE SMALL
ISLAND NATIONS WERE MORE, BUT
THEY BACKED IT BECAUSE IT
CLEARLY DESCRIBES THE IMPORTANCE
OF KEEPING AVERAGE WARMING TO
1.5 DEGREES CELSIUS AND
RECOGNIZES THE CRITICAL NEED TO
CUT EMISSIONS DRAMATICALLY THIS
DECADE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND US ALL
THAT WE HAVE 98 MONTHS TO HALVE
GLOBAL EMISSIONS.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN 1.5 AND 2
DEGREES IS A DEATH SENTENCE FOR
US.
>> Reporter: THIS COP MADE
HISTORY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME INCLUDING
TEXTES THAT CALLS FOR COUNTRIES
TO MOVE ON FROM COAL, BUT THERE
WAS A DRAMATIC, LAST-MOMENT
TWIST.
INDIA AND OTHERS TEAMED UP TO
INSIST ON WEAKENING THAT SECTION
BY CHANGING ONE KEY WORD.
"PHASE OUT" BECAME --
>> ESCALATING EFFORT TO PHASE
DOWN COAL POWER.
>> Reporter: IT CAUSED DEEP
DISAPPOINTMENT.
>> THIS COMMITMENT ON COAL HAD
BEEN A BRIGHT SPOT IN THIS
PACKAGE.
IT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS WE WERE
HOPING TO CARRY OUT OF HERE AND
BACK HOME WITH PRIDE.
IT HURTS DEEPLY TO SEE THAT
BRIGHT SPOT DIM.
>> Reporter: THE CONFERENCE
PRESIDENT COULDN'T HIDE HIS
EMISSIONS.
>> I APOLOGIZE FOR THE WAY THIS
PROCESS HAS UNFOLDED, AND I AM
DEEPLY SORRY.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE DEEP
DISAPPOINTMENT.
BUT I THINK AS YOU HAVE NOTED,
IT'S ALSO VITAL THAT WE PROTECT
THIS PACKAGE.
>> Reporter: OUTSIDE THE ROOM,
ACTIVISTS AND EXPERTS PREDICTED
REAL CHANGE IS COMING AFTER
GLASGOW.
>> PHASING DOWN VERSUS PHASING
OUT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN PRACTICE?
>> WELL, I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK
THAT THE CHANGE OF THAT WORD
CHANGED THE SIGNAL, CHANGES THAT
SIGNAL.
THE SIGNAL IS THAT COAL IS ON
ITS WAY OUT.
>> THE BIG CHANGE HERE WAS
PEOPLE FINALLY GOT THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGE AND THE URGENCY
AND WE FINALLY GOT A PLAN THAT
MEETS THAT.
BUT IT'S NOW ROLL UP THE SLEEVES
TIME.
>> Reporter: SCIENTISTS SAY THE
WORLD NEEDS TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE.
THIS CONFERENCE JUST SUCCEEDED
IN KEEPING THE PROCESS ALIVE.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH TO ENSURE HOPE
SURVIVES TOO.
>> Reporter: EXTRAORDINARY TO
THINK THAT NEVER BEFORE, AFTER
ALMOST 30 YEARS OF THESE
CONFERENCES, HAVE THEY ENDED
WITH SPECIFIC FORMAL LANGUAGE
TALKING ABOUT THE NEED TO MOVE
ON FROM COAL.
THE POSITIVE TAKE IS THAT THIS
AGREEMENT REFLECTS THE URGENCY
OF THE RECENT SCIENTIFIC ADVANCE
AND WHAT'S AT STAKE AND,
CRUCIALLY, IT PROVIDES A PATH
FORWARD, AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COUNTRIES TO COME BACK NEXT YEAR
WITH MORE AMBITION, PARTICULARLY
IN THE SHORT TERM.
IT NOW FALLS TO THOSE COUNTRIES
TO DO WHAT THEY HAVE REPEATEDL